When I was at a hair salon for the first time in Japan,
before I had my hair cut, I should ask if they had ever cut a foreigner's hair.Trust me, if a
new co-worker asks you if you are free on Saturdays,
even if you are free.  I
feel like I have the right answer,
but there's something wrong with that.The
same office is open on Saturday mornings.Is it
Saturday morning?Um, yes, that's right.It was
just right.It was a marathon of death as a team.  I'm
thinking of taking on the challenge of running a marathon, and I'd
really like to have the same participants participate.Well,
how many minutes it takes to get to the nearest city is more
important than how many minutes it takes to get to the nearest station for the marathon.I'm
sorry for telling you that.  No, but
you're not her first foreign boyfriend.Even
if it's night and you suddenly start playing Yuro B,
you'd better resist the urge to drift while driving down a mountain road.If you move into a new apartment, it
'll be a nice place.  But the first thing you should do is
buy a black cockroach cap and
put it all over the room.It's too
late.The air is dry in the winter in Japan, so you'll
need to rent one.An ultrasonic
model.  Don't buy Kaburunrun, which can easily form in
Anpanman.It's not that
you don't actually hate natto, you're just too
used to it.No matter how
good the equipment is, there are gyms that are more than 3 parts away.
I won't be going there in a month. She said she wasn't mad.
Well, she's mad. The
sushi lunch box from the supermarket gets cheaper at night.
That smell doesn't stop until you finish eating it. And it does
n't smell until you throw it away. And that
garbage...  You don't even need to take out the garbage bag.The
plastic container will
remain in your apartment until it is disposed of in the garbage disposal.The first thing you need to do is to
learn how to write your address and
your name.
It's a lot of fun, especially during the first year,
but it's best to
work at a job where you get paid on a whim and
feel like you'll never be able to go back to your home country.  It's better to
go to a nearby shrine, throw it into a money box, and
pray to Aterasu than to deposit
money.For foreigners, you'll get a better return by going to a nearby shrine, throwing it into a gold box, and praying to Aterasu.In situations where you might want to use a foreign card,
don't use good Japanese.  Let's
go without telling anyone about the trip.Many
people don't buy a washlet because they think it's expensive, but it's worth more than the price.If you
get food poisoning even once, you'll
definitely know it's Japanese food.  There's nothing
wrong with praising someone all the time, but if you
diss them, you'll be kicked out of the
country faster than Johnny. Over the past 10 years, I've
tried all kinds of methods, but all of them have
failed. In Japan, there's no way to escape from Last Christmas.
Not
till